Now for the big quiz.
In all seriousness, this is the most
complicated exercise
I've given you so far this lesson.
I want you to implement the DetailsView
using the CursorLoader
and multiple TextView widgets.
And I've got some hints for you.
Use loaders not adapters.
What does this mean?
Well, it makes sense.
Your DetailView does not contain a list,
so you don't need to use an adapter.
but you can still use the loader pattern.
The loader pattern will automatically
observe for changes in the URI
with a CursorLoader.
The second thing you want
to do is pass the date into your intent.
The date is the important thing
that the DetailView needs
to have passed into it,
to properly query the content provider.
Now remember, you can actually get
the current location settings
from the utility function.
So all you really need is the date.
I hope that helps.